listo ya pasé por mi ropa a la
lavandería volvamos a las matemáticas
estábamos en este problema usa una suma
trapezoidal con 3 sub intervalos para
estimar el promedio de cuántas personas
estuvieron esperando en las primeras
cuatro horas ya habíamos hecho una
gráfica pero tenemos esta expresión
terrorífica usa una suma trapezoidal
para estimar el promedio de personas que
bla bla bla y eso se ve súper complicado
de hecho que yo recuerde creo que nunca
lleve eso de las sumas trapezoidales en
mis cursos de cálculo pero lo bueno es
que basta pensar de un poquito para
saber qué es lo que nos están
preguntando empecemos con esto del
promedio de una función en un intervalo
cuando promediamos números sumamos todo
y dividimos entre la cantidad vamos a
hacer algo parecido voy a llamarle al
promedio entonces nos queda a es igual a
1 entre y supongamos que el intervalo es
de ave tenemos que ponerle 1 entre menos
a por la integral de ave de f
de equis
y esto de aquí tiene sentido
geométricamente el promedio de una
función es el área bajo la curva que la
define entre la base eso tiene mucho
sentido verdad vamos al dibujo es decir
si queremos encontrar el promedio vamos
a sumar todo lo que está abajo y vamos a
dividir entre la longitud o la base de
la figura podemos pensarlo de otra forma
tomamos el valor medio de la función
vamos a ver en este caso quedaría como
que por aquí arriba verdad entonces si
tomamos el valor medio de la función y
lo multiplicamos por la base eso de ahí
nos debería de dar el área debajo de la
curva vámonos al álgebra para ver cómo
se ve es decir nos quedaría reescrito
como ve - a x a mayúscula es igual a la
integral de a a b de fx de x con esto en
mente pasemos a lo de los trapecios los
trapecios aparecen en la figura debajo
de la curva y entonces nos ayudan a
estimar la integral justo esto es la
idea vamos a sumar las áreas de los
trapecios con eso estimamos la integral
dividimos entre la longitud que es 4 y
eso nos va a dar una estimación del
promedio
vamos a borrar esto de acá para pasar a
las cuentas déjame tomar el borrador voy
a elegir esto ahí está en negro
ok entonces el problema nos da la pista
nos dice que tenemos tres intervalos en
el dibujo hay tres intervalos muy muy
natural es verdad tres intervalos super
naturales de hecho déjame dibujar los
voy a dibujar con una línea punteada en
amarillo algo así
bajamos hasta el 0 este de aquí delimita
el otro sub intervalo y ya está tenemos
3 trapecios este tenemos uno en medio y
tenemos uno hasta la derecha muy bien
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es encontrar el área de cada uno de
estos trapecios voy a delimitar los un
poco mejor para esto voy a marcar bien
sus orillas entonces voy a tomar mi
herramienta de línea y voy a tomar otro
color color verde entonces esta es la
orilla de uno de los trapecios esta es
la orilla de otro de los trapecios y
otra vez la idea es sumar el área de
cada uno de los trapecios dividir entre
la longitud del intervalo aquí el
intervalo mide 4 y listo
vamos a terminar entonces vamos a eso de
calcular las áreas de los trapecios cuál
es el área de este del primero lo que
tenemos que hacer para encontrar el área
es multiplicar la base entonces el área
de aquí es a ver voy a señalarlo es la
base que es simplemente 1 es 1 x el
promedio de ambas alturas entonces vamos
al asalto
a ver cuánto es aquí es 120 y 156
entonces el promedio de 120 y 156 es
pues haber sumados nos dan 276 276 entre
2 nos quedan 138 verdad entonces nos
queda uno por 138 que simplemente 138
ese es el área del primer trapecio vamos
al segundo el área del segundo lo voy a
marcar aquí con rosa mexicanos su base
es 212 entonces es 2 x el valor promedio
de 156 y 176 a ver el valor de estas dos
alturas a éste está más fácil que número
queda en medio de estos dos pues 166
entonces es 1.60 no perdón 166 estados
por 166 y finalmente cuál es el
área de este último trapecio pues para
encontrar el área tenemos que
multiplicar la base la base es 4 menos 3
y hay que multiplicar por el promedio de
las alturas cuál es el promedio de 176 y
es un medio x déjame mejor sacar la
calculadora para no equivocarnos
recuerda que podemos utilizarlas
entonces le ponemos 176 más 126 y eso
nos da igual a 302 entre 12 151 muy bien
entonces vamos a tachar esto y nos queda
151 cuál es el área total pues tenemos
que sumar las áreas de estos 3
lo metemos a la calculadora otra vez nos
queda
138 más dos veces 166
+ 151 enter 621 ese es el área total
debajo de los trapecios pero todavía no
acabamos porque nos piden encontrar un
estimado del promedio de la función
entonces tenemos que dividir el área
entre la base la base mide 4 es de 0 a 4
y entonces tenemos que dividir esta
expresión entre 4 le ponemos entre 4 nos
queda 155 punto 25
listo como dice la pregunta usando una
estimación trapezoidal con 3 sub
intervalos logramos encontrar el
promedio de la función hasta 4 y nos dio
150 y 5.25 como no nos piden redondear y
es un promedio de personas vamos a
dejarlo así no creo que haya ningún
problema en el examen
bueno vamos a la parte cual sigue así la
parte c
a ver creo que vamos a utilizar este
dibujo en la parte c solo déjame borrar
las cosas de la parte b y la pregunta
verdad vamos a borrar el enunciado vamos
a borrar esta respuesta un poquito de
esto
y voy a borrar con un poco más de
cuidado unas flechitas porque pues
seguro vamos a utilizar esta gráfica en
el siguiente inciso y pues va a ser muy
muy útil ya haberla hecho digo si estás
en el examen puedes volver a dibujarla
pero bueno ya la voy a dejar así creo
que ya me quedo más o menos bonito
partes y vamos a pasar a la parte se
deja voy al archivo para elegirla no
estáis seleccionando lo copiar vamos
aquí al programa
edición
pegar ahí está déjame leerlo dice párate
entre 0 y 9 es decir aquí entre 0 y 9
cual es la menor cantidad de veces para
las cuales l prima de t debe ser igual a
0 argumenta tu respuesta ok
l prima de t es la derivada de esta
función recuerda que esta función que
dibujamos es solo una aproximación
lineal realmente esto no es el dt si no
es una aproximación hecha con líneas
rectas como sabemos esto pues l prima de
hecho es dos veces diferenciable
entonces debe quedar muy suave la
gráfica real va a parecerse más o menos
a esto que voy a dibujar va a ser como
algo de este estilo va a subir se va a
mover suavemente pasando por cada uno de
los puntos luego se va a mover
suavemente hacia arriba y aquí va a
bajar
muy bien
lo que nos preguntan es el mínimo número
de veces que l prima dt debe ser igual a
0 cuando pasa esto pues sabemos que l
prima de t es igual a 0 cuando tenemos
un máximo local o cuando tenemos un
mínimo local o bueno en algunas
ocasiones eso pasa cuando tenemos un
punto de inflexión pero bueno no sabemos
realmente que aquí haya puntos de
inflexión en nuestro dibujo solo tenemos
algunos mínimos y algunos máximos
entonces vamos a responder a ojo de buen
cubero y luego vemos como lo
argumentamos a ver pues viendo la
gráfica como que por aquí le vamos a
tener un máximo local aproximadamente
debe quedar en este intervalo entonces
marco la pendiente cero de aquí aquí
pasa algo parecido el mínimo local nos
da una pendiente horizontal y finalmente
tenemos un tercer punto crítico que es
un máximo por aquí va entonces a ojo de
buen cubero encontramos dos máximos y un
mínimo en total son tres puntos críticos
y por tanto la derivada se anula tres
veces ahora vamos a la segunda parte que
es la argumentación estas preguntas me
gustan un poco más que aquellas en las
que nos pide
hacer cuentas porque siento que ayudan
más a darme cuenta si realmente estoy
entendiendo el concepto de fondo ahí te
va como lo explicaría yo todo se basa en
que la pendiente de la función l
intercambia su signo tres veces ves a
donde quiero llegar más o menos déjame
marcarlo en el dibujo para que se vea
más claro voy a utilizar una línea
gruesa y brillante entonces aquí tenemos
pendiente positiva
aquí negativa luego por aquí tenemos
pendiente positiva y finalmente tenemos
una pendiente negativa aquí en el examen
yo escribiría los siguientes puntos
clave número uno la función es dos veces
diferenciable y por tanto tiene derivada
y esta derivada es continua
déjame escribirlo por aquí a la derecha
la derivada es continua punto número dos
la derivada tiene tres cambios de signo
otra vez por ejemplo aquí tiene derivada
positiva y luego cambia a que la
derivada sea negativa número 3 como la
derivada es continua y cambia de signo
entonces en este intervalo tiene que
recorrer continuamente los números y
entonces no puede saltarse al ser
como este argumento se repite aquí
y el argumento se repite también en este
intervalo de acá y en este de aquí
entonces debe tomar tres veces el valor
cero listo continuamos con la parte de
en el siguiente vídeo